جدد الاتحاد الاوروبي رفضه الاعتراف
بالانقلاب العسكري في النيجر واكد دعمه
اجراءات مجموعه اكوس العقابيه ضد قاده
الانقلاب الذين امهلتهم اسبوعا للتراجع
عنه بينما امهلهم الاتحاد الافريقي
اسبوعين لتحقيق ذلك من ناحيتهما علقت
بريطانيا والمانيا مساعداتهما الاقتصاديه
لميامي بينما دعت موسكو للضبط النفس
واستعاده حكم القانون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما اسباب هذا الاجماع
الغربي الافريقيه على رفض الانقلاب في
النيجر وما تاثيراته المحتمله على مسار
الاحداث في البلاد كذلك ما هي خيارات
القاده العسكريين للتعامل مع العزله
الاقليميه والدوليه التي تتشكل ضدهم ومع
التبعات المحتمله لوقف برامج الدعم
الاوروبيه والامريكيه لبلادهم واخيرا ما
مدى امكانيه حصول قاده الانقلاب على دعم
روسي في مقابل الرفض الغربي وكيف ستتعامل
الدول الغربيه مع اي دعم خارجي مباشر او
غير مباشر لقاده الانقلاب
[موسيقى]
على وقع ادانات افريقيه صارمه لقاده
الانقلاب وعقوبات عليهم ومنحهم مهلتي
اسبوع واسبوعين من قبل مجموعه الاكواس
والاتحاد الافريقي على التوالي توالت
المواقف الغربيه الصارمه ضد الانقلاب في
نيامي فقد جدد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جزر بوريل تاييد الاتحاد
جميع الاجراءات المعتمده من قبل مجموعه
اكوس ضد قاده الانقلاب واكد الدعم موقف
المجموعه بسرعه وحزم وقال برايلنا الرئيس
محمد بازون المنتخب الديمقراطيا لا يزال
هو رئيس الدوله النيجيري الوحيد ولا يمكن
الاعتراف باي سلطه اخرى داعيا الى تمكينه
من استعاده منصبه دون تاخير ودون شرط
ومع تجديد فرنسا عدم اعترافها بالوضع
الجديد في النيجر والذي علقت مساعداتها
الاقتصاديه له تماما كما فعلت واشنطن
انضمت دول غربيه اخرى حتى من بين تلك التي
لا تربطها مصالح مباشره مع النيجر فالموقف
الغربي المتشدد ضد انقلاب ميامي ازاءه
اعلنت بريطانيا تعليق مساعداتها التنمويه
طويله الامد للنيجر ودعت الى اعاده الرئيس
المنتخب محمد بازون والعوده الى المسار
الدستوري فورا
ومن جانبها قالت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان
الوضع في النيجر في تغير مستمر وانه لن يت
لديها في هذه المرحله لاجلاء رعاياها من
هناك كما اعلن المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الالمانيه تعليق مساعدات التنميه ودعم
ميزانيه النيجر اما في موسكو التي يتهمها
الكثيرون بدعم انقلاب النيجر وقد قال
الكريم ان الوضع في البلاد مبعث قلق شديد
ودعا كل الاطراف في البلاد الى ضبط النفس
والعوده الى النظام القانوني في اقرب فرصه
بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
ولمراقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا الدكتور
ادريس ايت الاكاديمي والباحث المتخصص في
الشؤون الافريقيه
ومن باريس لازلي فارين مديره معهد اليقظه
لدراسه العلاقات الدوليه والاستراتيجيه
والخبيره في الشان الافريقي اهلا وسهلا
بكما فيما وراء الخبر وابدا مع سيد ادريس
اذا من المعتاد انا منظمات اقليميه ودوليه
ان تدين اي حركه انقلابيه في اي مكان ولكن
الطريقه التي تمت ادانه انقلاب النيجر
تحديدا الاخير هل تختلف
تحيه طيبه وتحيه خاصه من قناه الجزيره
والمشاهدين اه نعم جميع المراكبين وكذلك
المحللين السياسيين حتى عامه الشعب
اتفقوا جميعا ان هذه المره العقوبات اكثر
صرامه واكثر
تجديدا والادانات جاءت باصوات اكثر قسوه
من اي انقلاب اخر في المحيط الاقليمي وذلك
اعتقد ان سببه كان مجموعه الاجراءات
المتخذه في بواكيل هذا العام 2023
الفين 2023 باعتبار ان الانقلابات هذه تجب
ان تكون تاريخا ماضيا للكره الافريقيه
وخاصه منطقه الساحل التي تعرف النظام
العمر والتدحر الورده الاقتصادي وكذلك
ايضا الموجات الجفاف والحجره الغير
الشرعيه فارادوا ان يكون اخر وكان الرئيس
بازون من بين الذين اتخذوا قرارا ديسمبر
الماضي قبل بدايه العام ان تكون هناك قوه
اقليميه غير ايكوغم القديم ان تكون قوه
اقليميه لا تحدث شيئين اولا الانقلابات او
التغييرات الغير الدستوريه في منطقه
الغربي افريقيا اضافه الى محاولات التمرد
في المنطقه وذلك هذا ما يفسر ان الرئيس
النيجيريا في نفس الوقت
ان احدنا من الذين وقال الاتفاقيه السابقه
يعتبر رهينه لدى الانقلابيين حاليا وهذا
العاطفه لدى القاده السياسيين في قمه ابو
جاء اضيف الى ذلك انه حاله جمهوريه النيجر
وعلاقتها مع فرنسا وانتبارها اخر معقل
للكتله الغربيه في منطقه الساحل بعد
فقدانها غينيا كوناكري ثم بوركينا ثم مالي
ثم بوركينا فاسو لا يمكن ان تكون اللهجه
اقل شده من هذه وتجب ان تصل الرساله
الغربيه والمنظمات تتعامل مع هذا الانقلاب
كانه اولا انقلاب في القاره ما سر هذا
التشدد برايك
اعتقد ان المواقف متشدده لان هناك تبعات
التراكميه بعد مالي وبعد بوركينا فاسو
وبالتالي هذا الانقلاب ياتي بعد سلسله من
الانقلابات وهذا يقود قدره المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا وقدره
البلدان الغربيه على منع هذه الانقلابات
هذا اولا السبب الثاني الذي يمكن ان اتحدث
عنه وان النيجر هو بلد في غايه الاهميه
وهناك تواجد كبير عسكري ليس فقط فرنسي بل
ايضا امريكي وايطالي والماني اذا هناك
تواجد تقريبا للجميع في النيجر ولذلك
برايي لهذين السب
نرى هذه المواقف الرافضه بشكل قد تعيد
لهذه
لهذا الانقلاب ولكن كما راينا في مالي في
العام 2018
وكان هناك
انقلاب لم يطلب اعاده الرئيس الى منصبه
بعد هذا الانقلاب وايضا ذلك حصل في
بوركينا فاسو الان الوضع معقد ان يطلب ان
يعود الرئيس محمد بازوم الى تولي سده
الرئاسه نحن نعرف ان الوضع في غايه
التعقيد نعم حتى من دول ليس لديها يعني
مصالح مباشره ادريس ايه مع النيجر هذا
الموقف المتشدد والمطالبات الصارمه هل
يتوقع ان تستجيب لها قاده الانقلاب
قياده الانقلاب
نعم قال للاجابه على سؤالك اود ان اجيب
على السؤال الذي قبله ان دولا ليس لها
مصالح مباشره كالمانيا اعتقد ان هذا الوضع
ربما ليس لها مصالح مباشره لكن يختلف
اللامبريطانيا لكن يختلفا عندما نتحدث عن
جوانب الامنيه وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالهجره
الغير الشرقيه باعتبار ان النيجر هي
البوابه الاساسيه لكل الدول الغربيه
افريقيا التي تمر الى البحر الابيض
المتوسط باعتباره حدودها مع الجزائر وكذلك
ايضا ليبيا هم الدولتان المصدرتان للهجره
غير الشرعيه من منطقه غرب افريقيا ففي كل
عشره من المهاجرين غير الشرقيين سته منهم
في منطقه غرب افريقيا وتعرف المانيا كما
تعرفون استاذه وبريطانيا تبعات الهجره
التي تاتي من هذه المنطقه وهذا الذي يفسر
مساعداتها فعالم مباشره غير اقتصاديه وهي
امنيه الهجره الغير الشريعه فيما يتعلق
بمواقفها المتشدد ولماذا فاعتقد ان هذا
ينزل الموت الاستراتيجي او الجيوستراتيجي
لجمهوريه النينجا فهي الدوله الوحيده في
منطقه غرب افريقيا التي لها امتداد ما
جميع مناطق القاره الافريقيه بماسيمال
خدودها
والجزائر ثم منطقه الساحل تشاد ثم منطقه
غرب افريقيا
وكذلك جمهوريه التي تعرف حركات
الداحشيه للاستجابه لكل هذه الضغوط اذا هل
ترى امكانيه للاستجابه للضغوط
لا توجد امكانيه لكنه يستعملوا الورقه
الرابعه وورقه الشعب هناك معادات شهور
الغرب وخاصه لفرنسا واستخدام هذه الورقه
يستحيل ان تكون هناك تدخل عسكري من وجهه
النظر
ادريس ايه يعني اثار نقطه مهمه جدا وهو
ملف الهجره وكنا نعرف بالنسبه
لاوروبا تحديدا والغرب بشكل عام ما يعنيه
هذا الملف هناك مثل نستعمله في العربيه
يقول على نفسها جنه براقش وما يعادل
بالانجليزيه ان يقوم الانسان
ربما اطلاق النار على قدمه هل الغرب مستعد
للتضحيه بمصالحه من اجل ملاحظه انقلاب في
بلد مثل النيجر
بالتاكيد ان هناك مشكله الهجره التي اشرتم
اليها والدول الاوروبيه اذا بالنسبه الى
موضوع
الهجره غير
القانونيه او غير النظاميه هناك
تدابير كبيره لتفادي هذه الموجات من
الهجره هذا مهم ولكن انا افكر بشكل اكبر
بموقف الاستراتيجي كما تفضل الدكتور
ايتن هناك موقع جيو استراتيجي والحدود مع
ليبيا مع مالي مع بوركينا فاسو
والنيجر هو الدوله الاخيره في منطقه
الساحل التي فيها تواجدا للدول الغربيه
ويجب ان لا ننسى القواعد الكبرى للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في
هذا هو الموقع الاخير في منطقه الساحل
طبعا في فرنسا هناك تواجد في تشاد ولكن
ايضا هذا المكان الاخير لتواجد الفرنسي
كذلك هناك خوفا تجاه خساره النفوذ
والاراضي والتواجد في تلك المنطقه هذا
بالنسبه الي السبب الرئيسي الذي يدعو الى
هذه المواقف طيب هناك خوف من هذا الجانب
ولكن الى اي حد يذهب هذا الخ
وف في الادريس بمعنى ان قاده الانقلاب
واضح انهم يعني
مستعدين لايقاف صادرات الذهب واليورانيوم
الى فرنسا مثلا هذه هذا ما تقوله بعض
التقارير وذلك ابتداء من يوم الاحد اذا ما
حدث ذلك بالفعل وصحت هذه التقارير ما الذي
سيكون تاثير ذلك على النيجر وعلى فرنسا
كذلك
فيما يتعلق
بالاحتمالات والتداعيات ذلك وخاصه اذا ما
كانت هناك مواقف متشدده
وابداعت ذلك الى تدخل باي نوع من الانواع
انا اعتقد ان فرنسا ستكون الخاسر الاكبر
ان المجلس العسكري انتقال وصل الى نقطه
الى عوده كل مراكب بعين فاحشه يدرك انه
التدابير التي اتخذتها وخاصمت تصريحات
وكذلك ايضا الدعوه الى المسيره التي
استحدثت السفاره الفرنسيه اوصلتها الى
نقطه العوده ما في علاقتها مع فرنسا
وفرنسا تدرك ذلك فاعتقد انه توجد الريحه
ثلاثه حلول وهو اولا ان تدعم او ان تدعم
انقلاب ضد الانقلاب وهذا اذا نتائجه قد
تكون عكسيه قد تكون او ان
ها تدعم الدول القوات للتدخل العسكري وهذا
ايضا لا يستطيع ان يضمن انه لا يعزازي
الامر وتكون مصابيح محدده
ان هذا هو الحل الباقي حتى بعد اسبوع وبعد
اسبوعين كما اتى المجلس الامن الاجتهاد
الافريقي سيبقى حل التفاوض امامهم لانهم
لا يخون ان يغامروا بفتره المصالح
الاقتصاديه وقتل اير هناك لان الذهب
الكثيرون ينسى ذلك فلا يمكن ان تغامروا في
هذا اما فيما يتعلق بمجلس العسكري يراهنون
على الموقف الشعبي وكذلك يد المحيط
الاكليمي باعتبار ان التحديدات مثيره قدمت
لوجهت ضد وكذلك بوركينا فاسو الموقف
الشعبي هل سيصمد اذا ما فعلا كانت البلاد
في عزله وكان هناك حصار سياسي واقتصادي هل
الرهان على هذه الورقه في محله
الحقيقه انه لا يمكن الجزر بذلك لكن
الكثيرون يقولون اذا صمدت مالي لماذا لا
ابتدات نحو روسيا لانه حتى الان لم يعلن
ولا انا لاي دوله اخرى غير الكتله الغربيه
وخاصه ان التعاون لا يزال الى حد بينه
وبين الولايات المرتده الامريكيه نعم حتى
يتعلق بقضيه المصالح الغربيه
واستعمالها كورقه من قبل قاده الانقلاب هل
يمكن ان تجدي وان فعلا يتم اللجوء الى
التفاوض وتكون ورقه ناجحه بالنسبه
للانقلابيين ام ممكن ان تدفع الدول
الغربيه وفرنسا تحديدا الى اتخاذ موقف
اكثر صرامه
الى اليورانيوم هناك حديث واسع نطاق
بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع ولكنه غير مهم
بمستوى كبير بالنسبه الى فرنسا هناك مصادر
اخرى يمكن ان تلجا اليها ولكن بالنسبه الى
موضوع البترول البترول الذي اكتشف في
النيجر هذه هذا امر اخر اذا بالنسبه الى
سؤالكم
النقطه الاساسيه هي كما سبق واسلفنا
الموقع الاستراتيجي للنيجر كما سبق واسلفت
الموقع الاخير للتواجد العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه من الساحل نعم راينا ما حصل في
مالي اذن العقوبات سوف تؤذي الشعب النيجر
هو دوله فقيره العقوبات سوف تؤدي الى
تباعات على الاقتصاد وهذا يؤدي الى الرد
عكسي ربما يمكن ان
نطرح النقطه
الا وهي
هذا الوضع يحصل لان انتخابات التي حصلت في
العام 2021 لم تكن
ديمقراطيه بشكل كبير والشعب في النيجر
يعرف ذلك اذا الانقلاب الان لا يحصل بين
ليله وضحاها كان متوقعا الانتخابات التي
حصلت في العام 2021 لم تكن انتخابات حره
ديمقراطيه كما يقال في وسائل الاعلام
وبالتالي الجميع كان يعرف ان
الشقاق سوف يظهر في مرحله ما وبالتالي لا
يمكننا ان نطلب عوده الرئيس محمد بازون
بالقول انه اتى نتيجه الانتخابات
ديمقراطيه كما قال جوير على سبيل المثال
وهذا بالضبط
يقول قاده الانقلاب دكتور ادريس ايه يعني
هو يعتبرون ان اسباب هي اسباب تصحيحيه
وليست قضيه ربما الخروج وتغييرات
جيوسياسيه وتغيير ولاءات ولكن يبقى السؤال
الكبير هو موقف الكرملين من كل ما جرى
يعني تحدثنا عن مواقف صارمه وتهديد
بعقوبات وما الى ذلك من دول غربيه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي من الامم المتحده ولكن
اكتفى بابداء قلقه مما يجري نحاول ان نفهم
هذا الموقف
الحقيقه انه الكرملين اه ليس لها عيون
انصح التعبير
دقيقه في جمهوريه النينجا حتى الان بقدر
ما لديها في بوركينا فاسو حتى
اظن ان موقفها موقف تريث لكن مبدئيا مع
الادانه حسب المبدا او قنديناسيوم
يفرض عليها ان تدين الانقلاب لكن فيما
يتعلق بالفوده الحاصل الان بين النيجر
وحلفائها السابقين الغربيين قد يستغلوا
الكرملين هذه الفرصه في اي وقت وهذا
بالضبط ما يؤدي الى دوله من وجهه نظر مثل
الولايات المتحده بلجيكا التي علقت
تعاونها العسكري لكن اوقفت
واصلت في تعونها فيما يتعلق بالتنميه
وغيرها اعتقد ان جميعهم يدركون انه كسره
الضغط ترديد الخناق قد يدفع بهم الى ان
يذهبوا الى روسيا وهذا بالضبط ما يتخوف
منه دوله مثل الولايات المطيره وكذا فرنسا
فاظن انها هذه الولاءات باعتبار انه حتى
الان لا يوجد قدم من القاده صرحت بذلك
تعتقد ان الامور
رفع الشعارات هنا وهناك في وقفات احتجاجيه
ليس هناك اي موقف صريح ولكن
كيف ينظر الغرب وفرنسا تحديدا الى موقف
الكريم والتصريحات من جانبه
اعتقد ان فرنسا تخشى او لديها مخاوف كبيره
بان يحصل في النيجر ما حصل في مالي اي ان
يؤدي هذا الانقلاب العسكري الذي حصل الى
تغير جذريه وان تكون خساره للدور الفرنسي
هذه هي الخشيه في فرنسا بالنسبه الى ما
يمكن ان تقوم به فرنسا والولايات المتحده
والمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
هذا هو السؤال الكبير لانه في الفتره
الراهنه هناك رفع للسقف وتهديد بالعقوبات
ولربما حديثا عن تدخل عسكري ولكن طبعا في
الفتره الراهنه براي هذه
التهديدات هي
لعرض العضلات او استعراض القوه ولكن هي ما
الذي يمكن القيام به بشكل عملي للخروج من
هذه الازمه
استعراض عضلات
هدوب من بعيد من جانب روسيا كيف سينعكس
الموقف الروسي على الموقف الغربي من
الانقلاب برايك
ان الغرب يرد بشكل عاطفي عاطفي وليس سياسي
ودبلوماسي لان هناك مخاوف منتشره في اوساط
الدول الغربيه بان تدخل روسيا الى النيجر
وبالتالي هناك عوده الى التاريخ التسلسل
التاريخي لما حصل في البلدان الافريقي
وبالتالي الموقف ليس عقلانيا هناك موقفا
عاطفي مخاوف من ان تدخل روسيا لتسد هذه
الثغرات بالنسبه الى روسيا الموقف اكثر
بساطه بالنسبه الى الاتحاد الروسي هذا بلد
روسيا غير منخرطه فيه حاليا وبالتالي
راينا الموقف الروسي على ما هو عليه
الموقف الغربي اكثر تعقيدا وخصوصا مع هذه
التهديدات بالتدخل العسكري هذا غير ممكن
ان الشعب
مع هذا التشبث الغربي
بالنيجر
بغض النظر عن حجم المصالح الروسيه ولكن هل
هناك خوف فعلا ان تتحول هذه الارض ارض
النيجر الى ساحه مواجهه بين روسيا والغرب
من جديد يعني نظرا لهذه المواقف المتشدده
الصارمه دكتور ادريس ايت ومن جانب الغرب
وكذلك التحدي من جانب الانقلابيين
نعم اعتقد انه من وجهه نظري لا اعتقد ان
الاهتمام وخاصه بما بمعرفه التامه لانصرهم
الكليه تقريبا اغلبهم اغلبهم يفضلون
التعاون مع الشعر النبدي الشعري يختلف لكن
الانقلابيين انفسهم اغلبهم يفضلون التعاون
الغربي الا التعاون الروسي لكن لكن هذا لا
يمنع ذلك انه يلوحون بذلك كورقه التفاوت
اورقه اللعب للتناقضات باعتبار انه اذا
ضغطتم علينا كثيرا سنتجه الى روسيا وهذه
الورقه نفسها
جيده
وقبل لدفع الدول الغربيه مره اخرى الى
التفاوض مع الانقلابين لكن وصل الى نقطه
العوده ولا يستطيع اذا ضغطوا عليهم كثيرا
الا يتجهوا نحو روسيا وروسيا ستفاوض
النيجر او حتى تقايدر الغربيين بدعمهم
لاوكرانيا وهذا ايضا الحرب البارده
الجديده الرقم
الايام القادمه ستشيب الكثير سنعرف اكثر
عن الموقف كله في النيجر شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور ادريس ايه المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه والباحث الاكاديمي واشكر لذه من
باريس وهي ايضا مديره معهد اليقظه لدراسه
الحلقه الدوليه والاستراتيجيه والخبيره في
الشان الافريقي ونشكركم مشاهدينا على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامجنا خبر لماذا
[موسيقى]